you very rarely see this and it's going
to get a lot worse that's the border
fence between Mexico in the United
States migrants from the newly arriving
caravans in Tijuana scaling the steel
railings they're inches away from
America and San Diego in the distance in
truth if they jump they'll be caught in
seconds unless of course hundreds do it
at the same time it's a fact the US
border police watching on horseback quad
bike and car are fully aware of the
sound of helicopters is never far away
anymore and that is unusual America is
increasingly jumpy about that migrant
caravans the border is monitored and
controlled every day of the year of
course but the migrant caravans and the
rhetoric of President Trump and his
military deployment has raised the
stakes the migrants are currently in a
Sports Complex they spend a lot of time
sleeping many are exhausted they've
travelled thousands of miles to get here
by and large they want to claim asylum
in the United States most are escaping
endemic crime and poverty in their
Central and South American countries
over half are children some of them very
tiny indeed Juana was born on the
journey north
she's a month and 17 days old her mother
or Linda and dad Juan are escaping the
El Salvadorian gang ms-13 one two killed
a couple for informing on a gangster he
murdered two people the gang member is
all Linda's brother
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
- Diaz
become more material and they don't make
the sink when you're the presume
the truth is these people really have no
choice but to wait and pray for
sanctuary in the United States Camino Co
menorahs Ostrava har ki-moon Aveda mejor
the United States is increasing security
along this fence because it is quite
likely that more people will attempt to
cross illegally the point is though that
most of the migrants wanted course
legally saying that they have a
legitimate case for asylum now that
poses something of a conundrum for
President Trump because these people
have done nothing wrong and there is a
process that allows them to enter the
United States these demonstrators want
the migrants to be kicked out of Tijuana
and they don't care in which direction
the police prevented them from reaching
the migrants camp it wasn't a big
protest but with more migrants do here
it could grow into something much more
serious the route to the United States
just got a lot harder to travel for
everyone this is the border crossing
used by thousands every day but the
lanes have been reduced or even closed
cross-border trade and travel is vital
to Mexico it's chaos here and everyone
is now affected still Ramzi Sky News
Tijuana